where we flies a dogs were folks happy
boy the glory he lives inside of Terry
Porter's head well football Friday what
do we have here
but where the Timberwolves put your
guard down boy what's your name
I'm Wiggins this is cat we're both
number one picks and squeeze of the year
as are so and what about the skinny one
I do cool dunks Saturday well who are
you I'm Dame Lillard the fellow here
with the ball that's CJ who do you play
for the Brotherhood with one banner will
learn our way to get a banner of our own
are you now sir Garnett said anything is
possible so you can help us out or leave
us be
I'm gonna be honest with you I couldn't
tell you how to get in a championship
but I can show you how to make it to the
second round
sir it's urgent
what easy warriors warriors have broken
into the gates
Beasley's been posterized Patrick
Beverly's ankles are broken and clutch
what happened to clutch his his head's
been ripped off Oh God
and the worst part is they did this with
only one splash brother damn it I cannot
be the only one on our fence we need to
upgrade our roster I don't know if if
that's the problem my god they left us
nerds
let me see that your defense is weak
signed a F who could that be
sir I use an I think that's actually I
know it is a Donnell file
oh the bastard is our the retirement
are we at Golden State yet almost but
well then where the hell are we just
passing through Phoenix it's a shortcut
Phoenix yes the suns they've been
eliminated for years to think how far
they'd fallen
I heard they used to have an offense so
fast they would score in seven seconds
every time they were the best at
everything except defense except offense
what was that
brick man they're going to try and jump
in the boat
did any of them touch you no I think
they went oh four five yeah they did
they definitely missed all
you